(audience clapping loudly)
- How are you?
- I'm good.
How you doing?
- You're in New York.
- I know I'm in New York.
- Yeah.
- You know,
I was a little tired,
but it's like this city,
it doesn't allow it.
Like, I was a little tired
this morning waking up
and they were like, nah, no, no, girl.
- Yeah.
- And like, yeah, the energy
of this city
- It's true.
kind of wakes you up, how do you like it?
You have to love New York.
You've been here so often
on and off.
- We love it, we love it,
working on something
meaningful in New York City,
there's nothing like it.
- Yeah.
- It's better than any
TV show, any movie,
I mean, this is pretty great.
- Yeah.
- Your own talk show's
pretty great.
- Yeah, oh, yeah.
(audience laughing loudly)
And I didn't plan this one.
- If you don't have this
you know, being a part of the
Broadway community and stuff,
it's like, there's nothing like it.
- That's what I feel so lucky for.
So now I live here, and I can just
go see shows all the time.
- That's right, that's right.
- That's amazing.
I don't have to like make a trip.
We both have very young kids.
Yours are two and six, right?
- That's right.
- Okay.
Are your kids musical?
- They are, yeah.
They are, I think they're
more talented than I ever was
at their ages, you know,
they...
- Sound like a parent.
(all laughing loudly)
- No, they're exposed to
it so much more than I was.
They're so much more comfortable
than I was, you know?
Yeah, they really...
How about yours?
Are your I...
- The same?
You know, now that you say that,
I think because they
grow up around it, right?
So they don't know any different.
So they've always seen mommy on stage,
they've always come on stage
when they were a babies.
So, like I think that they don't,
it kind of shakes off the
nerves a bit for them.
- Yeah.
- Yeah your voice is so magical
I was listening to you
earlier, oh, it's so good.
So what was like your
favorite song as a kid?
What's like, what'd you grow up?
- Oh, you know, I remember
the first grownup song,
I think we share this one.
The first grownup song that I really liked
was "Greatest Love of All Whitney."
(all chanting loudly)
- Did you put it on her pee in your room
and just keep belting it out?
- I did.
- Yeah, yeah, that's me.
(laughing gently)
Yeah, and my mom hated it.
Like, it's paying off now,
but it was a lot of...
We lived in a very small duplex.
(all laughing loudly)
Yeah, I don't think my
neighbors liked it either,
but it's like, herb songs were so fun,
especially that one And the
message, it makes you cry.
Yeah.
- What the message?
I remember there's this cassette tape
that I have from when I was a kid.
I had my own tape recorder in my room,
and I'm just doing that last, you know,
I'm just looping that the
final chorus, you know,
(imitating singing) (all laughing loudly)
no prodigy, no prodigy.
- And in your head you
are Whitney Houston.
- Oh Yes.
- You were like,
I'm killing this, yes oh my God.
And they had to listen
to it, (laughing loudly)
I love, I love that.
Did you ever do the,
'cause we're the same,
around the same age.
Did you ever do the like, play and record
to where you could record on your,
like that was with my first demo.
I did like the, you could kind
of mess with the tape on it
and then you could
record yourself on your,
so I recorded over people,
I was like, I don't like this anymore.
- Oh yeah, (all laughing loudly).
I would do my own background
vocals, you know what I mean?
Like.
- Oh, I was not that cool.
- Oh yeah 'cause you could, like,
if you record it on this side, you know,
then you put it on this side then.
- [Clarkson] Oh, the double, yes.
- Yeah and then you'd
keep flipping, like...
- You'd get the double for a minute, yeah.
That cost more, I was like,
yeah, that's really cool
you were rich, (all laughing loudly).
So wait, so, I didn't know this,
but you got your Broadway debut at 17.
I knew that you started in Rent I believe,
but like, I didn't know
it was at 17 years old.
That's very young.
- Yeah.
- What was your audition song for Rent?
'Cause it's such a powerful
message, it's such a big thing.
- I know, I sang the most
inappropriate R and B song
that, you know, for this rock show
I...
- [Clarkson] Like, he sweat.
Like, what were you saying?
Okay, (indistinct).
Oh, that's a great one.
♪ All we know ♪
- Yeah.
♪ We may never meet again ♪
- But, you know, for like,
(audience cheering loudly).
- So we should make something happen.
(audience clapping and cheering loudly)
Oh, that's beautiful.
- Yeah.
- You went for like, 'cause it's kind
of a funny musical to do that with though.
- [Leslie] Exactly.
- Depending on what
character you're going for.
- Yeah, no, it was...
- Can this one rock out so much?
And you're like, crooning them?
Like, yeah.
- But no, that show changed my life.
I honestly, like, I
didn't dream of a career
in entertainment on the arts.
I wanted to be in rent,
you know what I mean?
That's kind of...
- Specific.
- That's all I wanted, you know?
I thought I was going
to get it when I was 30,
retire from the show when I was like 40
and find something else to do.
- It's amazing though, when
something hits you like that
and it changes like the
trajectory of your life.
- Yeah.
That was lay miss for me, I
saw that at a young kid here.
It was my first time
in New York and I wept
and I was like a teenager,
so I did not look cool.
But like, I was like, oh my God.
And it was Jean Bajan
that one got me that song,
I was like, oh my God.
Anyway, I love when something
grabs a hold of you though,
and just like, changes your
life in the best of ways.
So, wait, I heard that you just got
your Philadelphia, is it
Music Walk of Fame, right?
- I did, yeah I got my
star on the Walk of Fame.
(audience clapping and cheering loudly)
- That's incredible.
What was the moment like for you?
That's like, where
you're from, that's cool.
- You know, it really touched me to
Philadelphia has meant
the world to me, you know,
and so you don't, I never considered that
maybe I might mean something
to Philadelphia too,
you know?
- Yeah.
- Just out here.
- That's a nice way to put it.
(audience clapping and cheering loudly)
(indistinct)
- People from my childhood
and from grade school
showed up to the ceremony,
which I also wasn't expecting.
It was pretty meaningful.
- That's pretty cool, man.
When you run into people, like
you knew when you were a kid
and it's just like, what happened?
I can't believe this happened, you know,
like everybody has this dream, like,
to be a part of this industry
and especially creative people, you know?
And we're very lucky.
- Amen.
- Yeah, I know blessed.
You're now back in New York
City or back on Broadway.
(audience clapping and
cheering loudly) So how
do you like it?
What's the show like?
How's it going?
- Oh, I'm loving it.
- It's purely victorious.
- Yes it's a show called Pearly Victorious
it hasn't been on Broadway in 62 years.
We brought this brilliant Ossie Davis play
he's a great American, a great
writer, you guys know him.
And we brought this play back,
revived this play after 62 years
and it's so joyful, it's
connecting with people.
It's found an audience, we've
been extended another month.
- Wow.
- At the music box theaters.
- Yeah.
(audience clapping and cheering loudly)
It's so cool, I love the wardrobe for it
to the time that it's...
- Oh yeah.
- It's very cool yeah.
- It's, you know, Pearl victorious
I think about Lin Manuel a lot, you know,
when I'm doing this show,
we got two of 'em today.
But I think about Lin Manuel
because, you know, it's
these two young writers
that writing about different
times, albeit different times,
writing about America,
writing about their country
and what it means to be an
American, very patriotic shows.
You should go see like
Pearl victorious matinee
and Hamilton at night.
- Yeah.
(indistinct)
- That's very important though
'cause I think a lot of kids
that got 'em into history as well.
Like, that's so funny that something like
On Broadway did that, but a lot of...
I was like, wait, what
are y'all talking about?
And just sparked a different kind of,
if we only taught like that, right?
In school and stuff
but you are in theater, so there you go.
So I have to say, I thought
this was kind of crazy.
So one of your theater classes
was actually taught by,
did Billy Porter, did he
step in for a bit of it?
- He did, yes.
Billy, I went to...
The college I went to was
Carnegie Mellon University,
and Billy's also a Carnegie grad.
(audience clapping and cheering loudly)
- I love him.
- He's the best.
- Yeah.
- And yet Billy came junior year
and taught for half a semester,
and he was like, the most impact.
I don't want to make any of my teachers...
- Demean anyone else,
we're not doing that yet.
- But Billy was...
He was an exceptional teacher
'cause he was a hero too.
- Yeah.
- He was a hero before then.
And he just came and changed
our lives really I, yeah.
- Oh, that's magical having a teacher like
that as well.
- [Leslie] I know.
- Oh, I love that you got
all that experience as a kid
that's why you're an amazing human.
So also why you're an amazing human
is, I recently heard
that you love journaling
I'm a huge.
- Yeah.
- Journal kid.
Now I get a little nervous
about someone finding it,
(laughing gently) but...
- [Leslie] I know.
- Yeah.
'Cause that's happened to me before.
Someone found it and like
read it and then accused me.
I like what was in it, and I was like,
you got, (indistinct) that's my mess.
I was like, wait, what?
I was like, you jumped in
that tornado, that's on you.
(laughing gently)
Yeah but like, I love it though.
It makes me feel good to get it out.
- Yeah it kind of...
It's an, yeah another
thing that's, you know,
will change a life I started waking up
an hour and a half, two hours
before my wife and my kids.
And...
- So you have you time?
- Yes my me time you know,
I'll journal, I do my yoga,
drink my coffee and stuff.
And it's a chance for me
to find out where I am
and before the day starts rushing in.
And you know, I've had realizations
for the record, you know,
I went through one of those
really tough seasons that's
kind of waiting for everybody,
you know, if you haven't
been through it yet,
just wait is coming, you know?
- Yeah.
- But, you know,
one of those seasons and I
journaled through the whole thing
and I really was just
honestly trying to make it
to the other side of that.
- Yeah.
- And I never was thinking
that I would use it creatively in any way,
but yeah, there, it dawned on me
this one day as I was listening to music
and, you know music was such a balm
and such a guiding light.
- Oh yeah.
- [Leslie] Through that time
it was like always...
- Healing.
- I'm supposed to use this,
I'm supposed to write about this,
you know, I'm supposed to make the record
that I needed to listen to, you know,
about going through this.
- Oh yeah that's like the goal, right?
That's something you would
want to get through as well.
Like, well, when Leslie actually
was making his album, "Mr"
he wrote in his journal,
"Finish the Task...
God needs some folks who are willing
and courageous enough to
finish what they started,
especially after he starts them."
- [Leslie] Right.
- I love that.
- Yeah.
- It's so beautiful.
(audience clapping and cheering loudly)
Do you feel like that still resonates?
- Yeah, I mean, every now and again that,
because the journey's long,
you know, it's a long journey
and you can lose your way
sometimes in the middle.
So I wrote that, that down
because I needed to remember
it, you know, I needed to...
- Almost remind yourself, yeah.
- That's right.
That it's like, it's not
always about judging yourself
and what you think is good
and what you think is worthy.
Finish it, finish the task.
You know, the inspiration is holy,
the inspiration to
start something I think,
you know, those things are like,
they come from somewhere and to
honor that original inspiration,
and the least you can do is
finish the task as best you can.
- Yeah, thank you, (audience
clapping and cheering loudly)
I agree with that, so tell
me about your new album.
This is...
I was listening to it all last night
it's different like, than
what I'm used to like hearing,
but it's so cool, it's different.
It's got, and especially how
you're performing it today,
because I also heard him earlier.
I love it how it's starting,
I feel like you should release
that version of it as well.
It's so great, but what is the reason,
like why did you need to do this album?
- Well, I mean, recording
is my favorite thing to do
other than Broadway, you
know, and doing talk shows.
- Good answer, (all laughing loudly).
- I love making these albums
and you know, the truth is,
we were almost finished on a
whole other record, you know,
and then kind of life came
and I went through this
traumatic, you know,
experience in my life a season.
- Yeah.
- One of those times.
And one, when I got back
to recording, you know,
I'm sure you've been through this too
you go back to sing those old songs
and you're like, I can't
even sing those anymore.
- [Clarkson] Oh...
- I gotta write.
- - Yeah.
- All new stuff.
So this was just that,
it's really, you know,
I had the realization
really about journaling
that whole thing, waking up
an hour and a half earlier,
all that stuff like, it
was three or four months
into doing that, that I realized
what I'm actually doing is loving myself.
This is what it looks like, you know.
- Man, (audience clapping
and cheering loudly)
and if you don't really know that,
like until your eyes are open to that.
- [Leslie] Yeah.
- Concept.
- And so this is an album
sort of about that process,
about that process of firstly learning
how to love your self you know,
it's the only way.
- [Clarkson] Yeah.
- That I have a prayer.
- 'Cause we're our worst critics, yeah.
- Oh my God.
- Absolutely.
- It's the only way that I have a chance
of having grace with my dear
ones, my beloved ones is
if I have some for myself.
- Absolutely and I don't
know if you can show it
unless you can like, feel it for yourself
as well.
- That's true.
- Like, you can't project it.
So your song, that's a good segue
so it's called "Loved."
- That's right.
- The one you're doing today.
Is that kind of the
inspiration behind that?
- Yeah, I, you know,
I was, there's just...
I'm sure you've had this
too, like, you know,
this realization about
the flexibility of time
when you have kids.
You know, there's times
when I'm looking at my son
and I almost feel like I'm
looking at myself and...
- Yeah.
- And I can almost feel, you know,
it'll be a blink before...
- Oh, I see how...
- I'm an old man.
- Especially my daughter,
and I'm like, oh my
God, I can see you at 20
this is scary.
- Right you know?
- Yeah.
- And so, anyways,
it's about that and I was feeling,
you know, kind of connected
to my grandparents,
even though they're no longer here
and it's about that there's
a refrain in the song.
Show 'em you've been loved,
show 'em how I loved you.
You know, if you've been loved by anybody.
- Yeah.
- In your life.
It's like, you know,
when you're looking for the
courage to take that next step,
when you're looking at
sometimes the courage to,
you know, go out and face
the world one more time,
it's like what you, you know,
if you don't have it within yourself,
I just, I heard my
grandparents saying that,
"Show the world that we loved you."
- Yeah and show him what love looks like
and feels like, yeah,
(audience clapping and cheering loudly).
Stay with us everybody,
because Leslie will be
singing later in the show,
you do not wanna miss, it's beautiful.
His new album is called
"When a Crooner Dies,"
it's out now.